hello hiya uh what's your name my name
is Eileen Aileen yep I'm guessing you're
from Ireland I am I'm from Derry oh he's
from dairy up to the north of the
country okay and he lived there we're
here uh story here I live over there all
right what are you studying uh costume
design costume interpretation okay there
will be subtitles on Friday
now only I can understand
I can't no so far you're not missing
anything
I've never heard of costume
interpretation yeah it's like costume
design isn't it
fancy it's fancier Frank oh yeah oh yeah
yeah all the Libra
okay all right off you go
so lead up to Christmas I was back home
um
did you get any of it Chris something
about Christmas Yeah Christmas that's
the only good detail so far just pick
out words you'll follow the story I say
blah blah blah Christmas blah blah blah
[Music]
and I had to get milk and bread
so I literally was being stressed so I
was like Ronan Ronald get the groceries
let's go told my boyfriend to do a lap
and just pick me up Noony they parked
the car so as planned I cameoi you know
perfect timing uh silver people carrier
just casually dressed by casual speed
it's without hesitation I Sprint across
when we look we made groceries
jump in the back of the car screaming
and dump in the back of the chair
shouting go go go go go
but taking a mind it was Christmas and I
had like a scarf up here
what which was my boyfriend turned out
to be this middle-aged like 60 year old
woman
poster food on the accelerator
[Applause]
round off
thing to give us a a some tips I would
say some tips unboxing we've got a very
very very high tech piece of equipment
over here uh so if you'd like to come
with me it's over here
[Applause]
I love this thing okay so I'll just turn
it on
hang on it's on it's on now oh okay
there we go so I hit that yeah okay
come on
it didn't show up this afternoon
what's happened to it sure Sharp
IE
are you serious
okay now
do you have any tips do you have any
tips because you're in high heels should
I take them off no not sure I think okay
we're taking this very seriously
he's talking to me
I mean no run-ups if you want to take
them off or whatever I wasn't even good
thinking about run-ups
so Rachel go for it no no don't don't
take your shoes off okay I'll just hit
like a girl in these yes so competitive
[Applause]
she slipped
do you want to go first Rachel or you
want to go oh I don't mind I just feel
like I could hit something you seem Keen
are you left or right-handed uh right
right so you know right leg back so you
really get the whole right leg back okay
the aim is just to get it so it goes
away it goes you do that you go boom and
it goes back up okay okay I honestly
mine was so bad so uh let's see what
Rachel gets and then I'll decide if I'm
going to do it
yeah
left leg forward yeah yeah are you in
range though are you in range oh I don't
know like shall I find out is that come
forward a bit come forward a bit because
you want to remember your aim is to
punch through the bag through so I want
to go like that yes I like that
[Applause]
oh
just have a stare down
who laughs first right
um okay
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
here we go here we go here we go
all right
okay
here we go look I'm still going okay
okay what was yours eight eight I think
it was three thousand
that was six seven two was it what six
seven two six three two so if you don't
beat back
I mean look at this
okay okay here we go here we go this
same technique is you the world champion
oh
well done the last time uh you guys were
on the show together and Anthony and
Greg they did a boxing Challenge and in
a bit of a shock result Anthony won
isn't it weird
heavyweight champion of the world would
beat a biscuit eating comedian
oh
yeah you should have both his arms tied
behind his back now so this time this
time we've got another challenge but the
last time it was you know those boxing
things and you hit the boxing there so
that's what we did the last time this
time we've gone for one of those fun
fair uh tests of strength machines okay
okay so if you'd like to bring in uh the
machine here it is
[Music]
foreign
you're going to have a bit of a Face-Off
in front of it okay okay we're taking
this seriously no no yeah we're taking
it seriously and it's not it's it is of
strength but I believe technique plays a
huge part so oh look
[Applause]
oh taller
yeah
okay okay
maybe I'll be turning up together
uh Ken Brown is going to give us a just
a little bit of form before we do this
okay you do your face off do your face
off come on come on okay off you go okay
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
tell him the postman because he always
delivers it's the Undisputed heavyweight
champion of the world Anthony Joshua
[Applause]
they call him how's he looking at
they can call him The Courier
The Courier because he sometimes
delivers
unless he gets stuck in traffic
it is Greg man Mountain damn
it so here we go here we go so AJ yeah
if you go first let's have you I thought
that was gonna be heavier okay
okay you go first mind the cameras here
we go
it's not goals
whoa oh dear
you go now you go now I know
[Applause]
so really it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter
well you might miss it as well
hit the Bell hit the Bell hit the Bell
thank you
Walk This Way
Walk This Way this way okay here we go
Anthony why don't you help Judy yeah
okay here we go
here tonight
I would stand I would stand very close
I'd say you're about there right there
okay here we go here we go here we go
ready okay sorry yeah
beautifully done hey you're better than
here
[Applause]
[Music]
we could have predicted that don't worry
about it
April the 13th been canceled
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
obviously your mother loves you because
you're her daughter but she is actually
a sort of a fan as well you know it's
not it's not quite that it's um no she
is oh goodness right so my uh uh one day
my mum came to set on the Star Wars set
uh and I was getting this thing called
cyber scans which is where you stand in
this kind of loads of cameras and they
kind of take your form and put you into
a computer and make a toy or a some sort
of merchandise or your face on a cushion
um and so I do often do this and I come
back and mum's like I've made a great
friend and I'm like brilliant it's
lovely excellent and she likes the
merchandise you know director of all of
Star Wars or something I'm like where
else very impressive
um and then before I know it what comes
in the post boost is loads of cushions
my face on it
my own mom would go she gets to see it a
fair amount you know whatever honey it's
not enough so yeah
kind of Blown Away how much merchandise
there is yes
it's just the beginning it was like the
pre-merchandise not even the real stuff
is out yet and my mum has all of it and
but doesn't know about the dog yet so
this is so weird I don't know is this in
your flat or her house right okay so
basically she's gonna be really funny if
I came home and it was everywhere in my
way okay so this is this is this is
Amelia's actual bedroom
[Laughter]
it was like a joke and then and then oh
oh and then oh my goodness we found the
photo but it's not like that now there
is another reason why I'm saying take
your first date back to that yeah
come on in
this little thing once I don't have a CV
I just have a bedroom
this is cool though so your mother a big
fan but Brad Pitt also a great big fan
that was the best night of my life yes
tell the story quickly
slippers uh no yeah there was this
auction thing that happened and um I
don't they called me and said would you
you know do you want to do you want to
um auction something off like maybe sort
of an experience watching the show with
you or something and I was like okay if
it's lovely it's great for charity yeah
it'll be for some you know some
something yeah and it'll be fine anyway
so I get there and it's amazing it'll be
a good thing
um I get there and it's basically like
this it's basically it's the Oscars like
there's so many celebrities in this room
and I suddenly remember that I said that
I would auction something off and so the
fear grows so I was petrified absolutely
petrified and then um the the person
whose table I was on is a friend and he
was being very kind and kind of put the
paddle up and I was like thanks very
much that's very sweet that will be that
and then someone else's paddle up went
up across the other side of the room and
I didn't really know and then suddenly
it was sort of becoming a bit of money
and I was kind of thinking oh she's
absolutely mental and someone went into
Brad Pitt and I was like LOL
When I look over to the room and he's
got his paddle up Brad's paddle
foreign
I think it's probably all set up
personally who was my friend ended up
you know doing the highest bid but um
but uh yeah I just kind of looked over
with just the most insane Emoji heart
eyes being like this is just the
gracious moment of my life because it
was quite nice that we sat beside Dawn
because then it's like being at home
sitting on the sofa with the hair and
everything
because yes well I think I had the hair
first I have to say I'm quite a lot
older than his daughter yes yes oh
that's her there now yeah
look at us
similar it is very similar this is what
you're going to be looking at in another
20 years time this is it I'll be on wife
three by then
she feels so special
but Dawn might move on because other
Dawn yeah because she
meeting men it seems even in your
presence Chris
uh no oh yeah she does
um he does she does well like anybody
would we've had a couple of things where
um so we met Brad Pitt right see at the
baftas I think it was
um he came over and he was uh we were
having a chat about something or other
and um uh he was very nice and I
introduced him to Dawn and they shook
hands and then we kind of kept on
talking and then he started talking to
somebody else or whatever and then after
a while I looked down and I realized
that she was still holding two of his
fingers
I was like we better go to our seats I
was like okay and she said 41 seconds
I said what that's how long I held him
for
two weeks after that
and um
Bradley Cooper was there very nice guy
very kind of personable yeah so who
that's how
it activities and we were leaving
and she was getting her phone out of her
bag and I noticed something sparkling
and I realized that she had stolen his
Fork
how did she saying that she was going to
auction it for charity or something but
every now and again at home
I see you're eating with it
it's kind of it's hard to feel like a
sex symbol when your wife is using
another month
to hold on to his fingers that's right
so hands up everybody here who's
actually been kissed on the lips by Brad
Pitt whoa
[Applause]
Now The Best Exotic Marigold Hotel It's
a Lovely Hotel not all Hotel experiences
are as good now we do have some
first-hand uh knowledge of this because
Sharon Horgan where were you a
chambermaid I was a chamber made in I
think it was the Imperial Hotel or
something that sounds like that
it was weird
it was my first job after leaving school
and uh so I spent a summer making beds
and scrubbing
um human excrement out of uh toilet
bowls can I think but at least it was
out of toilet because
we all held our breath there
but it's uh it's weird because I don't
think I I don't think there was a single
toilet bowl that wasn't kind of
decorated
it's because when people go on holiday
they're just like I deserve to not clean
my own crap out of my toilet bowl I'm
just gonna let someone else is that what
holiday says to you
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
picking your knickers off the ground if
you're in a hotel because you think
someone's going to come along and pick
up my knickers and this is from the
woman who did the picking up
exciting I always thought that you know
I might meet someone you know in a sort
of chamber maybe maybe an attractive man
you know you know I'm sure you saw that
movie with JLo didn't you yeah
because dangerous you have quite
exacting well not just acting but you're
very specific you are very regular with
your hotel habits
regular
she's on holidays
don't you when you're in London don't
you always stay in the same room I do I
do well no not the same room the same
hotel but this is where you've got your
own dressing gown they have give me a
dressing gown
which had JD on it which I was very very
proud of but then I had a kind of sneaky
feeling that maybe
if Johnny Depp stayed there he did
now or the guy from JD Sports yes
there are lots of people but now they
put djd on it yes two right now it's
yours now
well here's the thing thanks to the
World Wide Web anyone can now review a
hotel right and uh so we've come and got
these are actual online reviews of
actual experiences people have in hotels
so here's first one I got to the hotel
to check in and on my way to the
elevator I slid right into a pile of
diarrhea
it goes up my knees and my arm as well
as my luggage
the hotel staff did not help me in any
shape or form and told me to watch where
I was going
how is it my fault there is poop on the
floor in the first place my room was
horrible it smelled like poop as well I
was disgusted never again now what I
like about this is
one of two people found that review
helpful
another person no that's not helpful
yeah he still gave it one star yeah I
know Isaac having looked at these I
think one's the minimum you can't do a
no star uh what's up next uh please take
notice that this review me and my
husband and two kids went to these
apartments for a week and I must say
never again we arrived at 5am and were
introduced by a member of staff izmet I
said you've got passports we sat down
and my daughter 13. saw two people on
the sofa next to the bar making love
whilst being videoed by the chef
they weren't doing a good job
making love Yeah
but I like I like the service still got
two stars
location was excellent
uh next up
do not stay in this absolute dumb photo
and I use the remote tell very Loosely I
cannot convey strongly enough how
disgusting the space is blood State
headboards have nearly been up since
World War the first one
windows in one closed no hot water
broken Furniture don't utensils broken
light fittings an actual poo in the
kettle
now that's a holiday
sure I am so on holiday
David let's see the next one I wish we
hadn't gone oh no this is a weird one I
don't know whether it's an actual
spelling mistake or whether it's
autocorrect but it makes the review very
confusing indeed I wish we hadn't gone
the meal was ruined by midgets
everywhere
and we were sitting inside
we even moved tables near the back wall
all right they're followed by them or
they were at that table too we woke up
following morning covered in bites and
very itchy
terrible that's the hotel in Disneyland
though
all over the place get off do we have
another one oh this is this is oh this
is well anyway
we were given the keys to the wrong room
and walked into the room to find a naked
African gentleman washing his genitals
in the sink
are you Whispering Edge
[Applause]
oh my gosh when daffodil writes a book
this is in it and then I said to them to
the test washing his genitals
next one oh this is the final one this
is nice I like this person this person
is just a sense of verse they've been
around the block because not all the
reviews are bad this is just someone who
kind of understands the world and sees
the positive
for the price I paid to stay on New
York's Upper West Side I was surprised
it wasn't worse the room smell like
armpits and years are filled but there
weren't any creepy crawlies and I found
the staff to be most gracious and
helpful I could have done without the
bloodstain mattress and the actual chunk
of poop on my bedspread but I didn't
expect the Hilton overall in a pinch I
would stay there again
it's like this this is this is how good
it was they were quite happy to give me
new bedspreads when I reported the poop
just got time to go for the visit to the
big red chair uh hello hello hello hi
what's your name uh James James love you
James and what do you do I'm a civil
servant a civil servant lovely in London
here uh yes in London are you from the
London area uh no I live in London but
I'm originally from um Suffolk oh oh
yeah it's a Suffolk massive yeah
as you mentioned in the song probably
yeah what what school did you go to
um so I went to brandiston oh sweet yeah
I went to Primary School yeah oh okay
did we know each other yeah did we
go
James hello yeah James yes me that's the
one what the [__]
dude it's my best mate growing up you're
kidding
and now you're talking to me on a
monitor
specs and he's like oh my god oh can we
not flip him and just get him out of
here
do you have a story or do you well yeah
I did but please let it be about Edge
or February
Okay
cool so um yeah this is so randomly
that's really weird um yeah when we were
younger Ed used to come around to my
house and yeah like you're saying we
used to be quite good mates
um and I remember one time
um one time he was coming around for tea
um and I forgotten to tell mum who's a
vegetarian
um at that point anyway and um so mum
cooked I think the sausage and mashed
for tea
um and Ed said you know after the meal
these are the best sausages I've ever
tasted you know where did you get them
from and Mum had to lie because she had
no clue
um and so yeah 16 years later I'm really
sorry first time I ever had me and also
the first time I ever watched The
Simpsons episode was around your house
as well
yeah
okay well done you we're gonna flip you
now and then uh we could be reunited
backstage
I feel like Cilla Black on surprise
surprise
[Applause]
will you just say randomly
have a seat have a seat dude
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I remember sitting next to Phoebe Waller
bridge I remember talking to her before
the show and I'm going to tell the story
and I don't know what I don't know if I
should I don't know if this is because
uh I'm just worried about my mind you
know I I don't want people to think of
me because it's good it's quite is this
a bad story and she sort of told me what
the story was I thought this is great so
it's a perfect Graham Norton Show tale
backstage there are some Japes with
actors you know sure sure you know you
know yeah but keep the other actors kind
of uh um entertained when it's a really
long run and I'm really sorry mum that
I'm telling the story
um and there was one I was doing hay
fever and it was a three month run and
uh there was one moment there's one
moment on the stage where I was off
stage with this other actor Sam and one
of the other actors played by one of the
cameras played by uh Freddie Foxx would
storm across the stage open this door
and we'd be standing behind the door you
know masked from the audience and he had
to go and then he'd slam the door and
run back onto the stage and so we always
used to do something kind of quirky
behind the door to make him laugh
and every night we started off by doing
a little like oh like we're kissing or
like oh we put a funny hat on Sam but it
was three months long this run and we
had to up the game every night every
single night and so we started getting
the stage management involved and there
were massive like hot dog costumes and
like before people from outside to come
into every time Freddie would open the
door he'd be like really excited and
he'd be like
they changed really quickly and then run
onto the stage and other cast members
could see it and it was building a
building and we were running out of
ideas and it was like a week left and we
were exhausting ourselves and then
suddenly it was getting to the last
night we were like we have to have a big
finish like what are we gonna do for
Freddie and neither of us could think of
anything and suddenly we did the math
name we'd done this kind of wild kind of
like spangly glittery thing and then on
the final performance we had nothing and
we were like we have to do something we
have to do something we could hear
Freddie coming across the stage and we
were like we haven't thought of anything
said just I know I've got it but just
show them your [__]
is
[Laughter]
this huge pink skirt on no it's a random
story I love this leech big skirt on
everyone's like it's gonna be great I
was like yeah it's gonna be oh my God
what's happening down and everybody was
right
Olivia Coleman Lindsey Duncan Kevin
McNally all going
too far
Emma for you what is the hold that the
Spice Girls have over you is this real
yes it's real and I just feel like I've
been talking more about the Spice Girls
on this press tour than I have about the
movie
so you went to Australia I know I wept
did you really weep I really did but now
which one was talking to you Melby and
was she really talked to you was it a
message no it was a video message on an
iPad and that made you cry yes were you
jet-lagged yeah but I also you don't I
mean I you do understand because we're
in the UK I was I was a fiend I was
obsessed with the Spice Girls and they
taught me about girl power and I love
them I think they're fantastic and I'm
what's the song there's so many Jamie
there's so many
things spice up your life every morning
there's so many and they're so fantastic
and today on the radio
um Mel C talked to me over Skype so it's
really very exciting okay who would you
say is your favorite Spice Girl Emma
Bunton Baby Spice she's your favorite
she's my favorite who's next
to that just a question all of the other
four
so Emma Bunton well Emma Bunton was the
one that I had blonde hair and bangs and
my name obviously is now Emma my name
was Emily but it was taken
when I became an actor
um and so now it's Emma and uh yeah I
just I love so give me this so so you
one gave you a video message and want to
talk to you on Skype yes but you're
telling me you've never met are you
gonna do something have you never
satisfied are you gonna do something
really have you never met a spice girl
I'm wait hold on I have to mentally
prepare myself
have you never met a Spice Girl not in
the flesh okay now as you know as you
know as you know Emma he's very rare it
is very rare for more than one Spice
Girl
to appear together for
[Applause]
for at all
so they're not here
[Applause]
can any of you explain this tweet that
was sent to the show
uh I hope you all are happy with
yourselves been looking forward to this
verse this is Thomas so which of you
knows Thomas
you what's your name
um I'm Jessica Jessica and why is Thomas
upset with us
um Thomas is upset because I've um
postponed a date for the second time so
I could come and be here
for everything is he your boyfriend no
no I we have not been on a date yet
because like so you put him up what did
you put him off for the first time my
sister and this time Kylie okay you know
that book Not That Into You
to him
you don't know
that into him
can I suggest you take him out tomorrow
night when this is on
[Applause]
this week's visit to the red chair just
before we go uh hello who's there hello
sir hello what's your name Thomas okay
and where are you from I'm from Durham
Durham all right but you live here now
yes okay very good off you go with the
story Thomas uh so I asked a girl a
couple of weeks ago and she said yes uh
which was great because she's quite hot
and uh like I'm really good
[Applause]
once
schedule for tonight
[Applause]
I thought I'd come down and see if she
wanted to rearrange for next week
Thomas you're very keen because she has
given you no indication
[Laughter]
he didn't make other plans that's good
yeah okay so so this is your decision
now this is you this is you sending a
message to him so Jessica are we going
to flip Thomas or we're going to let
Thomas walk this is oh okay
Kylie please will you leave him off the
red chest
oh
[Applause]
my God
oh my goodness literally dumped
[Applause]
they never even went on a date and he
got dumped oh oh he's gonna be having
nightmares the rest of his life
oh
they finally came up with a good uh with
the story I read it I thought it was
awesome I thought it was great and I as
I read it I read about the character
that um uh Ryan Ryan that's right
um came to play and I said and I with
great enthusiasm I called up the
producers and I said this is great I
can't wait to hear blah blah blah and uh
what a great part why don't we see if we
can get
um
Ryan
Gosling yeah and they said oh uh
[Laughter]
this is a great part for uh Ryan Gosling
and they said we've been talking to him
for months now wait a second they'd only
been talking to me for weeks
so let's bring us wrong with the eve
going abroad and eating in restaurants
abroad is oh fraught with danger ladies
and gentlemen uh because we found a
selection of poor and sometimes right
like just essentially lazy translations
into English on foreign menus okay so
imagine we're all in a restaurant
together yeah and like to understand it
I said what are you going to get and
Stanley might reply well I'm going to
get
the sausage and the father-in-law
believe me
I don't know but the images that
conjures up
it must be some sort of toad in the hole
Yeah it's getting worse this this isn't
I mean really I mean I don't think
anybody relative in it yeah and I don't
think anyone wants this German type
sexual harassment
[Laughter]
I don't think it can go wrong with a
nice place of
hand shredded ass meat
's favorite do you want some more just
another handful
what do you have next this is
[Laughter]
having a wine pairing menu
oh this is a special brunch for the
weekend I might have the Fresh Salad
followed by a variety of opinions
but then sometimes people are just a bit
lazy so this one this bigger menu
there's some smoke cow feed and then
they're just cow something
I don't know
it's just beef in it
but that person took a bit of trouble
this next person couldn't be bothered at
all item number two on the menu whatever
food in it it's food
have it it's only your dinner you eat
again
we move on to dessert now ladies and
gentlemen oh oh let's all let's all of a
bowl of no sweet scum
it's not sweet scum you can get
strawberries with stuff as well
if you really want to push the boat out
why not have some chocolate puke
everything
and finally is there anyone who live who
doesn't like sweet tight [__]
it translated
[Applause]
weird I'm don't answer this question if
you don't want to remember but I have I
don't know why you brought this up but I
did hear you discuss you had an
extraordinary disagreement with your
wife
about yourself do you know what I'm
talking about by myself you mean yes
yeah oh
yeah listen you know this story listen
with interest
one night as you do we were talking
about stuff I've done and I just have no
mention and of course being circumcised
I said
I think they're married they're married
they're allowed
she said
she said you're not circumcised
I said what do you mean you've only
known me if you I I all my life I
remember my mother telling me why
because it was fashionable at the time
she said you're not circumcised I said
that's ridiculous I should know if I'm
circumcised
conversation but the next day I happen
to be seeing my doctor
are you okay
I was seeing my doctor about my annual
physical of course so uh while he was
down there
I said excuse me oh by the way Irv
um my wife and I had a little
disagreement
um I I am circumcised am I because she
says I'm not and he goes
not
[Applause]
sure it's not possible so he looked down
again and he said hey I'm Jewish I know
the difference
that is a bizarre
I have grandchildren
you're gonna have to change your
Facebook status
no more beef stew
well there's more beef stew
why haven't we seen more of you two
together
it's a pairing it really is it's a match
made in heaven
now and Jackie Chan yes Jackie Chan uh
yes what I haven't done that once I'm
very sorry I'm sitting on my hands I'm
going Jackie Chan I'm not doing that
because is it true that everyone just
goes to Jackie Chan yeah
I really hate that you know whatever I
go you know in Europe America especially
the father's children
that's a Robert De Niro wow Dustin
Hoffman
one day one day I hope people wow that's
a Jackie Chan
I'm trying I'm trying to restrain myself
you just come from the the Cannes Film
Festival yeah Ken Film Festival do you
enjoy things like that are they fun or
is it
just that business the the whole thing
about the those big uh events they call
them you know particularly in Canada's
red carpet things and do you enjoy them
do you like doing that uh no I can't do
any of that I really can't I've seen you
I did go well have you on a red carpet I
don't think so no have you I've seen you
show up at things not much to be honest
but you've you've done Posh things
you've you've mixed with royal you've
met the queen haven't you I have met the
queen yes I have another cream at um I
think it was a uh one of those
receptions for people in the Arts you
should have been there Graham buddy I
was you were overlooked yes
you would be a dirty potty mouth
yeah I would you know what I was amazed
at with the queen and she's very tiny
which is something for me today because
I'm quite short and she moves as if on
Rollerblades she just slides up like
that there's no actual walkings guys I
don't know what's going on under there
as to where you are
you are where you are uh for a start you
have to you have to tussle with that
whole idea of will you curtsy won't you
Curtis will you curtsy and I decided
before no look Kurt seeing it's no I'm
not going to bow down before Roy I'm not
going to and then immediately you do
and then and then the queen says there
was a group of about four of us around
her and she says a very small thing you
know so are you enjoying the evening and
everybody goes like this
[Music]
I think people are just nervous are they
eager to please don't want to be
beheaded or something
I'm sure must think that she's a great
comedian or something
that's all she sees is people fawning
and laughing at everything Jesus
I was doing it
yes I do you mean I was in Hong Kong
I remember and a long long time ago my
English so bad in that time I remember
when Queen raise your hand use your hand
otherwise you're standing here
and you're right what you're Royal
Highness yes yes yeah I didn't have the
room your Royal Highness you're right
highness Dennis well we're playing
around oh Queen's coming here
what should I say then I see the queen
stop stop stop so quick
oh okay then when she comes you're ready
like you immediately bow
she stands still standing there the
people
oh
she keep talking to me
my head is empty I don't know what she's
talking about
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
of course I'm so happy just standing
here more than like a three minute five
minutes but I just don't go away please
don't talk to me anymore I don't know
how to answer back
but you have to just keep thinking like
you know you're not as young as you were
like I wasn't Young when I started
what will make what will it take to make
you stop
I don't know really the big old oh
I don't know what are you saying he's
saying it'll stop when you
[Applause]
when he gets too old to do the stunts
right or something that won't happen for
years so just enjoy yourself Joan all I
can do is stand in one spot or hold on
to something because I'm so
uncoordinated I can do that at any age
anybody can get into it and it's funny
you can get into a pool and fart and
make bubbles
thank you and as you get older trust me
it'll get easier
[Applause]
thank you
physically physically you do put
yourself in the firing line that was in
this movie you had the tooth knocked out
this time oh yes I I had a concussion
whiplash stitches in my hand dislocated
shoulder yeah there's been a lot of
breaks and sprains and concussions I
think the most psychologically damaging
was when I broke my penis a few years
ago I was I was trying to backflip a
motorcycle and I can't ride a motorcycle
and I came off the ramp I let go of the
bike it goes 20 feet in the air and
comes down and breaks its handlebars off
in my crotch so
yeah uh you know straight to the
hospital in surgery but that was like
over three years ago and I still have to
catheter twice a day like a 15 inch tube
about the size of a number two pencil
twice a day
wait a second a 15 inch tube lucky wife
a two inch tube would probably get the
job done
not completely but I have a 10 month old
son so it still works oh yeah yeah thank
you thank you
well listen that's I'd say the mashed up
penis is a very impressive injury about
600 people in our audience tonight so
let's see let's see if we can do better
than that uh we'll see who's hurt what
uh to hurt feelings right there
have you heard anything if you broke
anything no no never horse riding
anything no no no bungee gone wrong
nothing nothing
at all
can't help you Johnny oh you're looking
for something
here's broken something laughs
what were you up to I broke my nose I
walked into a tree
shopping actually it was um my first
week in high school I was in school Camp
it was an introduction to our new peers
a new life at high school I was
blindfolded and it was a trust game
[Laughter]
the people you went to school with
that's a really funny gift trust me woof
anyone else
having an injury I got a rubber stuck up
my nose
okay
[Applause]
I heard something else yeah that would
have been a really good injury
the how that happened a bit of the story
would have been repeat
s first time
did you do it yourself or did someone
else shove it up my brother dared me to
put a pencil up my nose and it you know
the yellow one to the pink rabbit do yes
do you know them yes
yes she told me I couldn't take it out
because it would have raised my memories
[Applause]
how old were you six oh but no permanent
damage
depends what you call permanent damage
your dad could you started so young your
dad was really kind of important in your
career my dad I used to drive me in the
gigs because I was I was too young he
performed in the clubs so that would
make
for long as I brought along a parent
which is pretty uncool
having to bring a note and saying that
you're all right to go on stage in these
comedy clubs and it used to drive me
everywhere all over Scotland but you've
been very nice you've rewarded them
handsomely you gave your repair to
lovely trip was it the orange Express
you sent them on I'm a dad's always to
hang for Trends he always wanted to go
on the Orient Express so for the
anniversary a couple of years ago I got
them the trip and my dad is the only guy
who's ever missed the train
yeah
for Innsbruck station to send me a text
and he's just like talking to me on the
phone when I've been on trains and going
Dad I'm on the train the signals pretty
bad so he presumes that you cannot send
a text from a train
well I mean as I'm driving through like
cross-country so he gets off before the
Train's Duty depart and he starts
sending me this big long text just going
son we've been winding down then gazing
at the tourillian mountains and he's
done the spell check
and I'm reading this text and I'm kind
of following up just going I just really
had a good time and it just goes shite
and it spent the train has just left
let's make this a wind up so I've
ignored it and then and our text and
then going call me son
fundam it does the international
ringtone and he's going oh I just got
off to send that texture mum's on there
she's getting the passports
bookstation and I was going you need to
go to information and try and explain to
somebody they don't know what I'm saying
I would speak any German no or English
so they just think it's just an exciting
Scottish guy that seemed the Orient
expressed
and then eventually he's explained
what's happened and they got in a taxi
and he had to they contacted somebody on
the train he pulled into this kind of
original stop and my dad was a high
speed sort of Chase he managed to catch
the train and he got on and they get a
standing over here
yeah
you didn't wear a blue coat weren't you
I wasn't blue yeah at the place you
showed which was next door to heesham
nuclear power station the thing is I've
got because I was I worked at a really
good one in Yarmouth Great Yarmouth got
sacked which is another story and then
uh it was sacked and then and was sent
to we'll move on to that in a minute
sent to this one sent to that one as a
sort of punishment it was like uh you're
going to Morecambe to do six months
because you have just you've just done
something what had you done
instead of cheeky in the 70s but now is
illegal
it was actually an incident where it was
my first attempt to stand up comedy and
uh what happened was I I'd always wanted
to do stand-up comedy I didn't have the
guts to do it I got very drunk I had a
go at doing it as a blue coat my mate
said to me just copy all the other
comedians at pontins and steal their
jokes and basically talk to the front
row so you're supposed to say where
you're from they say Scotland you say
who paid for your holiday where you're
from Wales you're making noise like a
sheep rubbish jokes right but I said
that's terrible he said don't worry
you're just padding what you're doing is
you're looking for comedy gold which is
where you're from they say Kent and you
say what did you call me right now at
polterge is this used to take the roof
off right
so I tried it but I was very drunk
so I go on stage
and I say where are you from
this bloke says Scotland I can't
remember the joke
say hello
are you from the guy says Wales
I'd black out and I go hi
and then I say anyone in from Kent
bloke shouts out me
and I said
oh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]